hi everyone my name is mao and i work
for dr jean-luc jannik at cornell today
i will share with you some unique
aspects of breeding for sugar kelp
zagrena lattissima
so kelp has mainly been used as a food
source for human consumption mostly in
asian countries lately in the u.s and in
the european countries more research are
interested in breeding kelp for biofuel
people also extract compounds from kelp
for pharmaceutical uses
the selective breeding on zagrana
japonica which is one type of kelp
started early in the 1940s in asian
countries
however kelp breeding in the u.s is
still at its infancy stage
in 2018
our collaborators went out to collect
wild samples from gulf of maine to
southern new england these two regions
are separated by cape cod kennel which
is known as the biogeographical barrier
for many other species we did find very
distinct subpopulation structure
between these two regions and the gulf
of maine population is the focus of
today's talk
kelp has a unique biphasic life cycle we
start from the sporophytes harvested
from ocean these are diploids and can be
phenotyped once sporophytes matures they
produce soros tissue
which is the reproductive tissue we
collect them let them induce spores in
the water these spores are free living
and floating around in the water which
is very different than row crop seeds we
have these spores go through flow
cytometry single cell sorting system
each spore then can develop into either
a female or male gametophytes
gametophytes are haploids we store each
gametophyte in a separate container and
this is our germplasm stock when
crossing we mix them and if
fertilization happens young sporophytes
will develop and then we spray them onto
seed string
four to five weeks later we transfer
them onto larger growth rope and plant
them on the farm
this is what it looks like with our
current breeding pipeline we start from
the wild spur of ice which is our
founder population from there we
generated this stock of gametophytes
which is of germplasm from that
germplasm we choose gametophytes to make
crosses and testing the progeny's
provides on farm
if by the time of harvesting these
sporophytes are mature and reproductive
we can then collect source tissue and
induce spores and to get the next
generation of gametophytes in the lab
this gametophyte takes at least a year
to grow and accumulate biomass in order
for us to make crosses for the next
generation so our current breeding
pipeline takes at least two years to
finish a breeding cycle
genomic selection happens for this
gametophyte stage where we genotype them
we use the field data from sporophytes
to build a model and predict the
breeding values for gametophytes so we
can pick the best gametophytes as
parents to make crosses
some pictures on how the pipeline looks
like here is when we collect a source
tissue clean them and then let them
induce spores in the lab in the water
once they're sorted the gametophytes can
happen and this shows gametophytes are
stored in flasks with sea water
and then when we cross we mix those tiny
amount of female and male gametophytes
mix them and then store back into flasks
this is after the mixture was already
sprayed onto the seed stream
then the seed string were transferred to
growing rope and ready to be planted in
the ocean
finally the crew is harvesting
we used a very typical augmented design
on the farm including line effects block
effects and ear effects using common
checks across different blocks once we
harvest this we would measure plot level
biomass traits as well as morphology
traits which indicates the blade length
width
thickness stipe length and type diameter
this is what it looks like
when we harvested the kelp we store them
in this huge container
and then we weigh each plot to get their
plot level wet weight
we then cut it to get subsamples
we also look for source tissue and store
them
for those individual blade measurements
we would keep the samples in the bags
first
and after we finish all the plot level
measurements we then go to each one of
those back and then start doing
individual measurements
so using these traits from sporophytes
we build genomic selection model and we
evaluated the accuracy between different
populations
in this case training populations are
data from year 2019 2020 and year 2021
it's used as the confirmation population
we also try to predict between 2019 and
2020.
so we use the pedigree and also marker
information to build a relationship
matrix the total individuals that's
included in this analysis are 950 so
this would include founders
gametophytes
sporophytes and the new generation of
gametophytes
we compared different models to test the
genomic selection accuracy the first one
is the base model g block model
we used both pedigree and markers
information the second one is general
combining ability and specific combining
ability model that's constructed in bglr
we compared using category plus markers
to construct the relationship matrix
versus only using the pedigree
in our case we have both pedigree and
markers estimated relationship matrix we
combine them using the actomir add-on
method in this figure for example he has
two pedigree matrix and one marker
estimated relationship matrix your
output is a combined kernel so in our
study we have pedigree estimated
relationship matrix for all the
individuals and then markers estimated
relationship matrix for the founders and
for the gametophytes we then combine all
of them using the package
here is trade heritability figure x-axis
represents different traits their
abbreviations are listed on the right
side y-axis is the trade heritability on
the left side of the dash bar here
represents biomass traits on the right
side represents morphology traits we do
see that morphology traits have higher
heritability than biomass traits the
first trait dry weight per meter which
is
the yield that we're interested in kelp
we do see that heritability for yield
trades varies from one year to another
which is also typical in row crops
and we had tested significant year
effects and genotype by environment
interaction
we then looked at the correlation among
these traits again above this dash bar
represents biomass trades below it
represents morphology traits the first
trait is dry weight per meter dry weight
perimeter is
significantly correlated with the force
trait which is blade density but not
with any of the morphology traits which
indicates if a blade is very small
within that plot those small blades may
grow denser and that in return
contribute to the weight
for genomic selection we first compare
different models on this figure x-axis
represents different models as i've
mentioned earlier y-axis is the gs
accuracy through cross-validation the
third one is general combining ability
and specific combining ability model
using both pedigree and markers
information it gives higher js accuracy
than the other two though the difference
is not significant
we then looked at the js prediction
accuracy between environments here
y-axis is the gs accuracy
and x-axis represents different traits
again we have biomass traits and
morphology traits except for blade
thickness morphology traits in general
gave higher just accuracy than biomass
trades between environments the first
one is the dry weight perimeter that's
what we are most interested in it had an
accuracy about 0.17 which is on the
lower range but it's still within the
range of gs accuracy for yield in row
crops we then added 2021 data as
confirmation set on this figure x-axis
represents different traits y-axis is
the gs accuracy different colors
represents training data set is from a
different year or years combination
again the gs accuracy varies and for the
first trade drive weight per meter is
around 0.2 it's still on the lower side
but that still falls within the range of
gs accuracy predicting between
environments for yield in row crops
many factors affect gs accuracy and we
assess the trade genetic correlation
between years we do see variation for
the same trade from one year to another
between year 2020 and 2021 which is in
gray bar more trades had larger genetic
correlation than the other year's
combinations this is likely due to that
year 2020 and year 2021 had similar
length of growing season which is longer
than year 2019
for dry weight per meter we estimated
almost zero phenotypic correlation
between years and so gs approach it's
still a little more predictive we do
think that the large year to year
environmental variation and g by e is
limiting our ability to selection
let's take a look at the breeding values
for dry weight per meter over
generations
x axis indicates 950 individuals each
dot represents each individual y-axis is
the breeding value for dry weight per
meter
different generations are shown by
different colors
black is the founder sporophytes green
other gametophytes from founders
these are also the parents of fun-grown
sporophytes which are in dark red dots
then we had a small amount of
gametophytes that are collected from
fungum sporophytes as shown in red
because gametophytes from those farm
tested sporophytes are collected at
random plots due to that soros tissue
ripened randomly on farm plots we do not
see any improvement of reading values
when you're comparing the red ones to
the green ones
although we did see some farm testes
profiles revealed some improvements as
they show higher breeding values than
the founder sporophytes
as you may have seen there are many
challenges that are unique to kelp
breeding compared to the row crops
in the past three seasons less than half
of the crosses we made generated useful
data the plot either did not grow or if
they grow but they become very patchy
for example you can see on the left side
of the plots that they grow somewhat
more uniformly than the plots on the
right side here we discard any data that
comes from a plot like those on the
right side
second there is a huge randomness on
whether or not soros tissue can ripen
when we harvest this would affect
whether or not we could select best
sporophytes to induce spores and produce
its next generation gametophytes
lastly
the gametophytes that we maintain in the
lab they grow really slow
in order to accumulate enough biomass
for making crosses it takes a lot of
efforts and time it's very labor
intensive to maintain those gametophytes
in the lab
we need to change seawater every week or
two and sometimes contamination could
also happen in the culture and then we
lose that gametophytes
here are some thoughts for next steps
we did a simulation study testing out
different scenarios in affecting our
gain of selection before we find that
high genetic gain could be achieved by
shortening our current breeding cycle
from two years to one year
we then tried a proof of concept
experiment this past season and
concluded that it is possible to
complete kelp life cycle within a year
on farm though we could only plant and
harvest a few of these individual
sporophytes
mostly still due to their parental
gametophytes biomass limitations
those sporophytes could not be tested as
meter long plots for yield but we could
incorporate them into our breeding
pipeline as common practices for early
stage nursery screening step
there are other breeding pipelines that
are worth assessing for example in order
to overcome the gametophyte's biomass
limitation we could make mixture plots
where multiple female and male
gametophytes are used much like in
forage breeding
our goal is to select communicates and
recommend to farmers in making hybrid
crosses
so far we do not have much data on
inbred lines though inbreeding
depression seemed very unlikely so we
need to continue our efforts in
developing inbred lines which could help
reduce labor from a long term as by then
we do not need the single cell sorting
step for the gametophytes
thank you for listening i'd like to
thank my advisors at cornell university
our collaborators at the university of
connecticut green wave bus hall ocean
graphic institution and our funding
source are part e welcome for questions
or comments and suggestions